(hip-hop music)
- Gary, right?
- Yes, sir.
- [Female] Thank you, Gary.
- [Male] Nice to meet you, Gary.
(cross talking)
- Hey, happy New Year.
Good to see you.
- [Gary] How are you? Good to see you.
- Oh my goodness, what's
going on over here?
- [Gary] I'm doing a daily vlog.
(hip-hop music)
A Suburban T6.
How are you, man?
- [Driver] Hi, how are you?
- Good to see you.
- [Driver] Good.
- How are you?
(hip-hop music)
- [Male receptionist]
Lights, camera, action?
Come on, let's go.
Ask me anything, ask me anything.
- [DRock] What's your
name? What's your job?
- [Gary] Who do you like
better, the Jets or the Giants?
- The Jets.
- Yes, man, my man.
- Record me taking his ID.
Record me doing my job,
so they can't say nothing.
(laughing)
Thank you, sir.
- [Gary] Thank you, man.
Have a great day.
- All right.
Yup, I'm taking his too,
making sure we all safe.
There you go, all right.
- [DRock] Have a good day.
- You too.
(elevator dings)
- How are you?
(people talking)
- [Female] Nice to meet you.
- I'm Gary Vaynerchuk.
These are my partners in
something called Vayner Capital.
- [Female] Nice to meet you.
- Okay.
- We invested in the last round.
I also run a 600-person
digital social shop.
- Gotcha.
- Yeah, that's good.
Cheers.
- How long you been a fan?
- I've been a fan since
probably the age of ten,
when I converted from a Giants fan.
- Tremendous move.
What year is that?
92?
- 92, yeah.
Pre-Kotite?
- Yeah.
- I don't even know where that is.
- Those were shit years.
- Oh, awful.
- I'll see ya. Real pleasure.
- Pleasure to meet you.
- Stay well.
- Yep, take care.
- Where you from?
- I'm from Philadelphia.
- Nice.
- But I went to Vanderbilt.
I had class, we talked about you in class,
down at school.
- Thanks, man.
I know, I'm old.
- No, no, it's good.
Very nice to meet you.
- Pleasure, man.
Stay well.
- You too.
- [Male] All right, we will be in touch.
Cheers.
- You're welcome.
- Yup.
- Thanks, man. So how long
you been here?
- Uh, three years.
I actually emailed you like six years ago,
and you responded.
- Thank you.
- Yeah, glad you did, now it's great.
- Pshew.
- Now I'll see you.
- All right, thanks, man.
- Thanks, man. Real pleasure.
Thank you brother.
- See you Monday.
- Appreciate it.
(hip-hop music)
- And a lot of the people, I know, and,
- I don't want you to fall.
- It's like my good luck charm actually.
I never tie my shoe.
Like, I will never tie my shoe-
- Have you ever tripped and fell?
- Maybe, like in third grade.
(all laugh)
- But, I never trip and fall,
and I think it's bad luck to stop.
I'll tie it when I sit down later,
but I'll never tie it
mid-noticing that it's untied.
- Time is precious.
- Time is--
You know what's so funny?
That's exactly what I think it is.
I literally think it's the time.
- That's what I think too.
- Get on the DailyVee.
- Best friends.
- [Gary] Get some followers.
- Follow me on Snapchat
at louisgeneux, let's go.
(laughing)
- Friday in Sundance,
- Yeah?
- Is it, am I not touching it?
- What do you want to do?
Are you just going to hang with Harwood?
- Yeah.
- And Ben Lerer?
- No calls--
- And Thursday too.
- Well, Thursday, you have--
- Do I have a couple of other things?
- Well, you get there on Thursday,
- And I have?
- Then you have a video
chat for that pitch.
- Yeah.
- So, that's the only thing I have.
I usually don't touch it.
- You can pitch me on something.
- Of course.
One more thing, stay there
and I need you to look at it.
- Great.
- Good.
- From Australia.
(laughs)
- Australia to Honolulu.
- But this is what you need to look at.
- Five hours.
- Layover.
So you're just sitting there.
- [Gary] And then to the--
Is that where I'm going?
To New York now?
- As of right now,
or you go to South Africa.
Or you go to like, it's
completely up in the air.
You know what I mean?
- Yeah, okay, well, I'll go.
I'll do the five-hour layover.
- Okay.
The next day,
- Are we doing South Africa?
- We just need to figure out a date.
- Well, it has to be that date.
- You think from Australia?
- Oh, we got the second
Australia trip in April?
- In May.
- In May, we have a second Australia trip?
- Yeah.
- Right.
So actually, you know what?
Do that, get me home.
- Okay.
Cause I mean--
- What can I do in a
five-hour layover in Hawaii?
- [DRock] A lot.
- Well, there's also a nine-hour--
- [DRock] Sorry.
- DRock, you're not supposed to
be talking in these things.
You just broke the wall.
I'm weirded out.
(laughter)
I know.
- (mumbles)
Interesting.
- Okay.
How about today?
- Today?
- The recording.
- It's exhausting.
- Think we're going to
have to get another day?
- [Kelsey] Gary?
- Oh, maybe two.
Such a pleasure, how are you?
- So nice to meet you.
Kesley Humphreys.
This is my husband, Chris.
- [Gary] Chris?
- [Chris] Nice to meet you.
- I drag him along.
- I know I have the hard
stop, so let's go fast.
- [Kelsey] Yeah, got it.
- I apologize, I started
a few minutes late.
- You started selling and
having success in sales
as a kid.
So, I mean, lemonade stands--
- I was like an infant.
- Right.
- Like, really young, right?
Like my daughter's six
now, she's in first grade.
I was already really selling.
- Wow.
- And so, when I look at
her and her classmates,
I'm like, man, I was a weird kid.
- They're going to give
us ten percent of revenue,
ticket sales,
to put towards votes afterwards.
- And above?
- In addition to the 4,000.
- Fantastic.
- Just trying to build one big event,
rather than two and a half or three.
- Okay.
- Alex, how's business?
- Booming.
I'm not saying it again.
- [Gary] What are you doing, Mike?
- My job.
- I understand.
(hip-hop music)
How's your day going?
- [Female] Good, just got around.
Got my walk in, in the nice weather.
- [Gary] It is nice today.
- Yeah. Is it spring?
It's Friday, I know that.
- [Rick] Hey there!
- [Gary] Hey!
- How are you, sir?
- Good to see you.
- Okay, good.
- How long can we go until today?
- Uh, what was it I said? Seven.
- Great, so that's good time.
- That's good.
- We should be able to do some damage.
- What up, Facebook?
DRock, I know you love
perfect lighting but eat it.
We're going this way, old school.
Wine library TV, 2007-style,
so I just want to add a
little color to this episode
about the audio book itself.
An opportunity for me
to create some clarity
on what exactly I'm doing.
Really excited about not
just creating a book that,
you know, is a replica of
the questions and answers
from the show.
Especially because even
before caring about
other audiences or new audiences,
I want to deliver for my core audience,
the people that support me,
the people that I bring
free value to every day.
I'm going to go in.
- [Rick] And I'm going to say yes,
good, let's do that.
And again, just before you do,
just to remind you what we're doing.
When the chapter begins,
you do the reading of sort
of the introductory material.
- [Gary] Yup.
- When the questions pop up,
- [Gary] I review the answers.
- You review the answers, so in fact,
we get as much out of the
book as you're comfortable
giving them.
- Yeah, your big concern,
what we ended with
yesterday was really good.
The only vulnerability is
possibly just leaving out
a little oomph to make
it as deep as possible.
- Right, and it's that.
A quick look, and then you answer it
as if it's a new question.
- [Gary] I think that a quick
look would help me make it
a little beefier than--
- Yeah, that's what I want.
- In the third, in the
early fourth quarter,
but towards the tail-end,
I think I was leaving a little off.
When you made that comment, I
think we finished off strong.
- Good.
- You agree?
- Yes.
- [Rick] Yes.
- (claps) Thanks, guys.
- Thank you.
The real play here was
a lot of new questions,
categorizing themes that have
happened over 175 episodes.
Ironically, there's almost three answers
to every question that's
come through down the pipe.
There was the answer I gave on the show.
There's the answer that I was
able to dramatically expand
on, or tweak, or even update in the book,
and now that I'm recording the audio book,
I'm kind of free-styling on top of that.
So, it might be fun for
people in the future
to ask me to create clarity
on three different answers,
though I have a funny feeling
that may be one question
through the whole book,
because the fact of the
matter is thematically,
and even in detail, they
should all match up.
So, very very excited about it.
Excited about the continuation
of dramatic content,
value, execution.
I'd like to switch your mindset.
I'd like you to think
about a supermarket, right?
So, supermarkets, if you think
about how they're laid out,
they have the essentials on
the opposite sides, right?
They try and make you go
as far as possible to milk,
because almost everybody coming in there
is going to buy milk.
Now, they don't block it.
You know, they may make
it kind of inconvenient,
and so, I would say,
there's a very fine line
on a website from a UI UX,
the layout of your site.
Are you going to do four
pop-ups before they get to
what they want?
You're going to lose them
by pop-up number two.
There's a way to find
that perfect Mendoza line,
between value for you and value for them.
- I've never thought about
where they put the milk.
- I know.
- It's brilliant, it really is.
- Thinking about the math--
- [Gary] Oh, so if you
owned a hockey team?
- If you owned a hockey team.
Okay, think about it.
Snapchat.
- I don't have to.
I've been in Snapchat coma for two months.
I'm ready. Two weeks, I'm ready, go.
(laughs)
- Let's say you owned a hockey team.
What would you do with Snapchat?
- I love this.
So first of all, if I owned a hockey team,
hopefully it would be
the New York Rangers.
Let's start with that.
I would understand that
what Snapchat offers me
right now, at this recording, early 2016,
is enormous opportunity
to win the heart and minds
of 13 to 30-year-olds in America,
and really shape the minds
of 13 to 18-year-olds.
And so, what I would do,
is I would take a step back and say, cool.
I know what the Rangers stand for.
I know what I want people
to think about the Rangers,
but the problem is, you
can't talk to a 16-year-old
about the Rangers the same
way you're going to talk
a 42-year-old, and so I
would try to think about
what's the cross-section
of relevancy, right?
For example, I would create
contests on our Snapchat stories
about date night for
high school kids, right?
High school kids care about dating.
That's kind of cool,
and so having great
seats against the glass
to impress that girl
that you've been chasing
your whole life, and finally
she's giving you a date,
that's cool.
That's a quick way to
go viral in Westchester,
amongst potential New York Ranger fans,
so what I would do is I would
kind of weirdly talk about,
by the way, this makes me
take another step back.
Real good job by the
order of these questions.
I would go back to what
I just talked about.
First, I would think about the
audience and their psychology
on Snapchat, they like
silly things, it's fun.
I would not overproduce content.
I think one of the
biggest mistakes right now
brands and individuals are doing,
is they're trying to make
their Snapchat content
too fancy, too good of lighting,
this is not a Hollywood blockbuster.
People want quick, raw
talent, you know, just quick,
I would take a video of Henrik Lundqvist,
but the lighting was bad,
you could kind of not
even make out King Henry.
I would make it very authentic and real,
and I would use it as if
I was a 16-year-old boy,
but that would be the Rangers account,
and then I would entice them,
with if they watch the story to the end,
to get that full engagement,
there was ways to enter contests
that brought them value.
So I would treat the platform
the way it's supposed to be treated,
and then I would create
incentives around the psychology
of that audience, based on
things that I could bring
them value,
and to me, the dating
culture kind of needs that.
There you go.
Honestly, I just can't wait to
get the stories in a year or two,
from everybody that read, "#AskGaryVee"
and had success from it.
Very honestly, it just
reminds me a lot more of
Crush It! than anything else.
In a weird way, #AskGaryVee
is really a Crush It 2.0.
A real blueprint of how to do it,
through the questions and answers and so,
I'm kind of getting impatient.
I'm kind of getting antsy waiting for
2018, 2019,
that's titled, Your Book Changed My Game.
(hip-hop music)